pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues d'abord
je voudrais remercier Bernard rilcro qui
a permis l'inversion de l'ordre de de
parole me permettant de de rentrer dans
mon bon département euh monsieur le
ministre notre groupe va vous aider à
équilibrer votre budget en vous donnant
quelques moyens de renflerer nos caisses
grâce à la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale les chiffres sont astronomiques
80 à 120 milliards manquent aux caisses
de l'État et notre groupe fait de ces
sujets un axe fort je salue tout d'abord
les dispositions des articles 19 20 et
21 avec une petite tendresse pour
l'article 22 relatif au prix de
transfert
euh dans le PLF à la fois sur la
première partie mais aussi sur le suite
nous vous nous vous proposerons quelques
dispositifs de matière de matière
regrettable persistante et anormal dit
la Cour des comptes dans son rapport de
2023 nous ne disposons d'aucun outil
d'évaluation de la fraude fiscale alors
vous avez réuni après l'excellente
impulsion de Gabriel Atal un groupe de
travail mais toujours pas d'instance
permanente pour cette évaluation et
pendant ce temps les voleurs courent
monsieur le ministre un fraudeur heureux
est un fraudeur qui revient le document
de politique transversal qui nous est
remis ne ne remplit pas son rôle dans
son
intégralité explication notamment des
des crédits du programme 156 sont
insuffisants les différents acteurs et
services concourant à la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale qui sont financé par
d'autres programmes ne figurent pas dans
le document de politique transversale
qui est techniquement fait pour ça
quelques exemples tracf dépend du du
programme 218 conduite et pilotage des
politiques économiques la brigade
nationale de la répression de la
délinquence financière B
nrdf dépend du programme
176 n'est pas non plus dans le le
document orange le budget du parquet
national financier qui est quand même un
sujet important dépend du programme 166
ne figure pas non plus dans le document
de politique transversale donc avoir un
document de politique transversale c'est
très important qui soit incomplet le
rend moins
opérant quelques
éléments de fond la fraude à l'arbitrage
des dividendes 150 milliards au plan
mondial 33 milliards pour la France
entre 2000 et 2020 nous allons vous
proposer au groupe de l'Union centriste
un amendement retoqué plusieurs fois
mais j'espère que la descente du parquet
national financier au printemps dernier
vous
motivera le ministre Atal qui vous a
précdé précédé annoncé un redressement
d'environ 2 milliards et demi d'euros le
deuxème point monsieur le ministre et
vous ne serez ser pas surpris euh
concerne une véritable lutte contre la
délinquence financière et les paradis
fiscaux avec un travail de fond sur les
conventions fiscales internationales un
scandale une annonce Nicolas sarkoi
avait annoncé à daauville les paradis
fiscaux c'est fini force et se constater
qu'ils ne se sont jamais aussi bien
portés la Suisse malgré ses problèmes et
ses promesses le Luxembourg les
ports-fanc aux portes de l'Europe et en
Europe le
lietenstein évidemment jersey nos amis
de Dubaï qui bass ce des milliards en
roubles ou en euros peu importe la liste
grise n'est pas non plus plus
satisfaisante on y retrouve des pays
amis comme l'Arménie bon et Israël et
toujours rien ni sur Dubaï ni sur la
Grande-Bretagne post brexit les règles
monsieur le ministre pour sortir de la
liste des territoires non coopératifs ne
sont pas sérieuses il s'agit simplement
de conclure une convention peu importe
qu'il y ait un acte vous savez que il y
a pas d'amour sans acte d'amour
on devrait appliquer la même chose aux
États et territoires non coopératif je
vais vous donner un petit exemple
l'oligarque Monsieur T s'est acheté un
Falcon 2000 bon 28 millions de dollars
une paille il l'a revendu pour un 900 LX
38 millions de dollars une paille et
enfin achète un 7 x 48 million de
dollars toujours une paille ces
appareils produits par Dassau ont été
livrés au Bourget sans que Monsieur T ne
paye la moindre TV
ces achats ayant été effectués par des
sociétés écran enregistré dans l'île de
manne en achetant ces avions monsieur té
a fauté la TVA à hauteur de 18 million
et demi d'euros c'est beaucoup d'argent
la prolifération des pardon voilà la
prolifération des jets privés est
synonyme de fraude fiscale il en est de
même pour les yach et le célèbre leasing
maltais au nez et à la barbe des
contribuables européens
ayons un débat régulier sur ces
questions et sur les conventions
fiscales au lieu d'avaliser sans aucun
pouvoir les conventions fiscales qui
nous sont proposé Éric bet l'a
d'ailleurs extrêmement bien démontré
lors de la dernier du dernier débat sur
la convention fiscal qui semblait
complètement anodine avec le Danemark et
la Grèce et qui en réalité masquait des
avantages nombreux pour les plus gros
acteurs du trafic maritime est-ce que
j'ai dépassé mon temps de parole oui
j'aurais beaucoup à vous dire sur
j'aurais beaucoup à vous dire notamment
sur les conventions judiciaires
d'intérêt public qui sont absolument
insupportables 1000 questions sur les
enquêteurs européen l'Agence européenne
de blanchiment la création d'une mission
budgétaire sur la fraudeélévation
fiscale et un ou plutôt une ministre
consacré à la fraude et à l'évasion
fiscale je vous remercieci merci chers
collègues la
parole est à notre collègue Thomas
Dosu